dans le ciel de kiev ce matin à l'aube
cette épaisse colonne de fumée noire
trois explosions ont été entendues dans
l'ouest de la ville cet immeuble
résidentiel vient d'être touché par un
missile comme hier l'impact a surpris
les habitants dans leur sommeil sonnés
ils sont mis à l'abri par les secours
ils ont à peine eu le temps de prendre
quelques affaires et d'emmener avec eux
leurs animaux de compagnie
20e jour de guerre en ukraine les
bombardements touche désormais des zones
jusque là épargnée cette gare a été
frappé ce matin c'est celle de
zaporizhya la ville refuge des habitants
de marioupol chez les séparatistes
pro-russes du dombass un missile
ukrainien cette fois a ravagé hier un
immeuble cet appartement est en ruine
mais ses habitants sont sains et saufs
à voler jusqu'ici ma grand-mère était
couchée juste là elle doit avoir un ange
gardien que ce dieu merci elle est en
vie
le président ukrainien implore l'aide de
la communauté internationale comme dans
cet appel diffusé cette nuit
tous les amis de l'ukraine à venir à qui
ça peut être dangereux c'est vrai qu'au
jeu mais nous remercieront tous ceux qui
nous rejoignent les ukrainiens comme les
étrangers
soutenir le cren sur son sol c'est ce
qu'ont fait hier les premiers ministres
polonais tchèques et slovènes à kiev
demandant à l'union européenne
d'accorder le statut de candidat à
l'ukraine
cet après midi face au congrès américain
le président hélène ce qui devrait une
nouvelle fois réclamé une zone
d'exclusion aérienne sur son territoire